c'est alain chamfort alors si vous
voulez écouter mes chansons vous cliquez
là si vous voulez vous abonner à ina
chanson vous cliquez là lassé du
contrôle de la force et de la souplesse
commencez à deux ans et sur la campagne
fois par semaine c'était un entraînement
assez régulier pour faire du mal allez
c'est par souci de l'image que vous
donnez de vous c'est pour moi après
brique moi j'ai des enfants je n'aurais
pu voir quand tu vas faire des choses
avec d'anciennes d'entretien c'est
quelqu'un maintenant qu'il a assez
d'autonomie à ces deux de savoir entre
guillemets pour pouvoir le faire tout
seul ça a travaillé sur l'esprit quand
on est déconnecté de la journée
après on est prêt à démarrer une journée
plus en possession de ses moyens
je suis plutôt optimiste même si j'ai
une nostalgie en moi des choses un peu
mélancolique comme ça mais je suis
plutôt ouais j'aime bien aller à la
découverte qu'est ce que la journée va
me réserver par exemple on va rentrer
dans l'atelier de pire chez rial qui est
un un auteur à un auteur un autre
monsieur qui fait des notes
qui crée des cartons perforés pour les
orgues de barbarie qu'est ce qui vous
fait rien si c'est un monde magique
regardez vous allez voir versement vous
auriez aimé être joueur rare pourquoi
pas mais je me suis dit qu'il y avait
une relation entre ma situation actuelle
sans maison de disques arrandale et rock
chantant dans les rues c'est la prière
privilégie la plainte du
blessé et je
au bout d'un moment
on est censé s'adapter
je crois qu'il a trop pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir mes chansons vous pouvez
vous abonner à la chaîne et la chanson